this is a production of Cornell
University
thanks Eric it's a pleasure to be here
and I'm gonna be talking today about how
best opportunities aren't found in other
words your career isn't put on a silver
platter for you but rather they're made
so the onus is on you to own your career
and we want to empower you to have the
tools so that you can be successful no
matter where you end up whether it's in
academia or somewhere beyond so let's
start with a little challenge since the
1980s the cumulative number of faculty
positions has remained relatively
constant as you can see in this orange
line at the bottom whereas the number of
PhDs awarded has been rising steadily
yet unemployment for PhDs in the
sciences and engineering fields is less
than the national average at about 4
percent so where does everybody end up
the American Society for cell biology
brought together several sources to
create this infographic for biology PhDs
that reveals faculty job is actually one
of the alternative careers PhDs are
successful in industry and government
research science related and non science
jobs about 30% are estimated to not do a
postdoc and about 30% do a second
postdoc for an average nationally of
about four years so the numbers don't
quite add up because it's really hard to
track information reliably on
internationals or on all postdocs in
general and these numbers were largely
based on the NIH biomedical workforce
working group which then identified an
opportunity to address this and as a
result they developed the best awards
for broadening experiences in scientific
training the goal is to develop
innovative approaches that complement
traditional research training in the
biomedical sciences so these awards were
given to now 17 institutions their
experimental awards funded by the NIH
Common Fund program office which is out
of the office of the director Francis
Collins
and Cornell is just one of the
consortium members that meet monthly via
teleconference and several times a year
in person to share best practices so
each institution has a different model
of how they run their best programs some
are working with small cohorts of 10 to
20 students a year and they all go
through the exact same programming and
at the end they get a best certificate
and they're ready for their job and at
Cornell we have a very different model
where it's kind of a smorgasbord where
you'll you'll learn more about what we
offer but it's much more inclusive some
like Wayne State offer programming that
includes the humanities and Social
Sciences as well so Cornell's best
program is focused on all STEM PhDs and
postdocs thanks to the additional
support of the Graduate School and the
colleges of Ag and life sciences arts
and sciences engineering human ecology
and veterinary medicine we enhance
opportunities to help trainees prepare
for their future careers so for alumni
historically what are those careers
especially for life scientists like you
at Cornell so the good news is they're
virtually all employed so two to five
years after PhD conferral about 30% are
in postdocs and two-thirds are employed
in positions other than postdoctoral
training with that percentage going to
94% when we survey Cornell alum PhD
alumni seven to twenty years out from
their degree so when we look at the
types of employers overall other than in
a postdoc about half end up in the
education sector in red here and a third
in the private sector or this green part
of the brain and about 10% end up in
government when we survey Cornell
doctoral alumni 44% shown here in the
blue graph at the beginning
seven to twenty years out from their PhD
report to be employed in four-year
colleges and universities or their
affiliated research institution about a
fifth are in industry but they're
employed at nonprofits foreign
educational institutions the US
government and so on in green you see
alumni two to five years post degree
when we're excluding the postdocs
they're the greatest shift we see is in
the is in employment in the industry
sector but we see an increasing
diversity in other forms of employment
either they're self-employed they're in
foreign governments they're in medical
schools or centers there might be in K
through 12 schools or community colleges
so if we look at the types of employers
and we just focus on the education
sector up here in red the great majority
are at four-year institutions
domestically and about 17% are in a
foreign institution so collectively they
are predominantly in various stages of
the tenure-track process as assistants
associates or full professors here in
green for alumni in the government
sector here in gold if we break it out
we see them the great majority seventy
one percent are at the federal level
domestically and maybe 22 percent in the
non-us government with six and a half
percent ending up in the state
government when we look at the industry
and nonprofit sector
the majority are in industry and 18
percent end up at nonprofits so with
this diversity of career outcomes for
Cornell alumni is really no surprise
that current PhDs and postdocs are all
started
interested in learning about all of the
possibilities the best brokest best
program focuses on four main career
tracks that fill the gap between the
excellent existing support that's here
on campus for teaching excellence and
academic research training including
careers in science communication so for
instance if you want to become a journal
editor or a science writer or a museum
director for example in science policy
so this this can encompasses both if you
want to be in creating policy to
regulate science or on the other side
for scientists who might want to
contribute to the policy-making aspect
also governance risk and compliance for
those who might consider becoming a
funding agency program officer or a head
of biosafety or an intellectual property
manager and Industry entrepreneurship
and management obviously there's overlap
between a lot of these buckets and this
is reflected by the interests of the
best program participants which I'll
share with you later so how do you get
involved and why are people interested
well they get involved to become a
besties first by going to our website
they fill out a short application about
what their career objectives are on we
schedule an individual consultation to
personalize the program to your
individual needs we invite you to come
to events join the cornell best linkedin
group or even hired a photographer to
come to take a nice professional
headshot if you want to improve your
LinkedIn profile somewhat you can work
on an individual development plan either
start one or if you've already got one
maybe it's a good time to review that
and the key point is to include your
professor your advisors in the
conversations that you're having about
your plans so that that can be
accomplished alongside of your research
objectives
so the more you know about your own
values and where you'd like to explore
the better we can tailor the program to
your individual needs so self
exploration really is key so from the
application besties express the most
interest in industry entrepreneurship
and management I mean it's a big bucket
to so here at the bottom you see 28%
have checked that off but a large
proportion are interested in a
combination of often involving science
communication and many just want to
learn about all the different tracks to
see what career possibilities are geared
toward phd's so two-thirds of the
applicants are actually in the life
sciences with about a third also in the
physical sciences and we have open door
programming so we often have people from
the social sciences and humanities join
us as well even though that's not our
focus
so they come from over 60 departments
across campus and and fields and of our
most active trainees compared to campus
totals proportionally fewer are postdocs
probably because if they come to a
research one institution they probably
want to become a tenure-track academic
professor and are set on their training
and proportionally more self-identifies
underrepresented minorities so our reach
as I said really extends beyond doctoral
students which are our folks I'm sorry
which are our folk that which are the
focus of our program and postdocs as
well we often have master students
undergrads and other people like staff
and faculty attend our programming by
college we have participation across the
disciplines with 40% coming from
engineering 30% roughly from Cal's and
and so on in the different sectors so
some hallmarks and now that you know a
little bit about our participants we we
kind of want to tell you what our
program actually offers so we actually
begin by reminding
everyone that your primary objective is
really to have a successful PhD
concentrate on your research and your
publications we don't want to distract
you from that most important job you
have here as a doctoral student or a
postdoc however with that in mind we
don't have any fixed requirements
because we know you're busy and we're
ready for you are to take advantage of
the program that we have when it's
convenient for you
so if you're right before your thesis
writing or before your a exam we don't
recommend you participate we'll catch
you up at a different time
so aside from filling out our
application which takes about 10 minutes
you can come to any events by choice
meet with program staff to learn how the
program could be customized to your
individual needs so whether you're a
first year grad student or a month away
from the end of your postdoc you can
come join in and tangibly benefit from
the professional development resources
so some of our participants haven't
really thought yet about considering
anything beyond academia or are
unfamiliar with the many options
available to them so at this stage we
provide exposure to the variety of
career outcomes to which PhDs are well
suited we share resources for specific
information to learn more about the
skills needed in a particular career
path and we guide activities that will
help rule in or rule out because we're
really agnostic as to what the career
outcome is we help you rule in or rule
out a particular option to help decide
whether the pros and cons mesh with your
individual objectives so at this stage
you might want to come to career panel
discussion on science communication or
other areas to hear how recent alumni
have transitioned from academia and what
they like most and least about their
jobs or about how they got there what
their path was you'll hear their
perspectives of firsthand and we often
have experienced managers share what
they most value in new PhD hires so it's
a chance for you to broaden your network
not just with alumni but with
like-minded colleagues from across camp
this in different disciplines so you
might want to go to for instance an
advancing science and policy club
meeting to learn more about what's
involved in connecting with policymaking
we've designed special gap-filling
courses and workshops to address needs
that aren't covered on campus so for
instance we have created what started
out as a workshop as a business as a
second language it's now a full-blown
course called business and management
fundamentals so you can learn more about
the business side of science which might
help you in academia as well so we
encourage you to get involved by going
to our website sign up for a lift serve
take the time to learn how we can be
used as a springboard for other
resources that are available to you
sometimes it's just a matter of learning
about where those resources exist
because we don't reinvent programming
for teaching or for entrepreneurship for
the most part because those resources
are really well developed across campus
so the key point of our program is
really that it's more about doing we
want you to apply what you learn and
write it on your resume so we can help
design and empower you to create an
experience that's customized to your
needs and might help others along the
way you have similar interests and we
hope that these experiences result in a
rule in or rule out that's okay to
decision and end up having you actively
acquire the skills that will set your
resume apart from all the other PhD
applicants so the second level of
participation for those who may be there
post a exam or they have a little more
time we we can help plan to prioritize
more experiential opportunities to try
on the particular
career learn firsthand whether it suits
you and to learn how to describe your
research in a way that will resonate
with the future employer so we hope that
each experience results in something you
can write on your resume to say not only
am i interested in science communication
but here's the lay article I wrote or
here's the blog I started or here's the
op-ed piece that that I contributed to
to affect policy or something along
those lines and we want you to be able
to say okay I've done that and then use
that experience when you're in an
interview situation to show that you you
have drawn from experience rather than
theoretical knowledge so how do we do
that I already mentioned some courses
you can take I mean there are over 70
courses across Cornell in
entrepreneurship alone one of our best
days is actually team piaying the
technology commercialization course
that's coming up I encourage you if
you're interested in that area to sign
up but we curate actually probably the
eight or ten entrepreneurial courses
that are open to PhDs and postdocs they
welcome scientists and engineers in
their classes to mingle with business
students and so we can save you some
time and perusing big long lists we have
offered certificates in Lean Six Sigma
thinking in by pharmaceutical regulatory
affairs and good clinical practices and
there you have a certificate on on your
resume that shows not just that you're
an expert in FDA regulations but at
least you're taking the active steps to
say you want to become more aware of the
regulatory path in industry for instance
so many people have entered business
plans they've participated in the three
minute thesis competition they've
successfully applied for internal seed
grants either through the Center for
Advanced Technology through statewide
Clean Energy grants or even through
federal programs for Small Business
Innovation research some have we have
two company start ups already from
besties
we have people invite speakers to
symposium like Eric did
and you you can be recommended I'm sorry
to be a speaker at an industry
conference yourself or moderate a career
panel that the best program puts on to
give you that leadership experience many
have gone on to either shape New York
legislations to have their policy brief
included in the clean energy bill passed
by the New York State Senate and we want
you to think creatively and flexibly
about internship experiences so we call
them best earn ships because we want to
get out of the mindset of what an
internship is that's typically 10 to 12
weeks full-time over the summer for an
undergrad phd's can really add value
over a longer term maybe perhaps
remotely and using the research skills
that you're developing during your
thesis work in your postdoctoral work so
key findings are that we want to be
flexible so for instance if you want to
stay in the lab and don't want to travel
off campus there are many existing
opportunities with within Cornell for
instance and the Environmental Health
and Safety Unit or in the licensing
office we've had bestie's embedded there
where they're on site sometimes but when
they have a lab experiment to go they go
back to the lab and they contribute
remotely in their own time doing market
research doing lab inspections as by a
safety officer for instance we have had
people arrange with their advisers to to
work off-campus two days a week for
instance at a venture capital investment
for accel partners to become a venture
analyst so that's kind of an unusual
path but it was personalized for this
individuals career goals we've had ones
who worked developing their own
technology with a startup firm in
Binghamton to implement their research
at a food science company we've had ones
who have used the time between their
thesis defense and their actual degree
conferral to
you a real internship a more classical
internship but for PhDs and this person
happened to be from Luxembourg and is
now fully employed at Bain as a
consultant so it was a way not only for
the company to check out his experience
but also for him to interview the
company to see if that's really where he
wanted to end up we've had students
participate a longer term with their
advisors consent and approval for
instance at a strategic analysis firm in
Washington DC where this student looked
at the regulations and perceptions
around gain-of-function studies for that
affected that moratorium on pathogenic
organism research and as a result of
that work the moratorium was lifted and
he contributed to that process others
have actually spent a greater amounts of
time at a large Pharma this is not usual
but this is to express the range of
possibilities that people have
successfully done and this student just
completed his PhD and realized that
maybe he doesn't want to go to that
biopharma company is gonna be working at
another one
so sometimes unexpected outcomes and you
know better you do that now while you're
doing your PhD and you might save
yourself some time later so we're trying
to start to change the culture we build
on existing seminar series to get a
captive audience in the room to spread
the word we encourage students to
suggest speakers who come from beyond
academia to come and speak within their
seminar series and as if that's the case
the best program will fund half the cost
of the travel and so it's a nice
incentive for departments to be open to
that so I'll share a few example
outcomes created by best trainees not to
say this is what we do but to get the
creative juices flowing so that you
might be inspired for what you might
want to do so for industry
entrepreneurship and management the best
program funded a postdoc to attend a
precede workshop which happened to be
happening in Rochester because his
technology was ready earlier than the
precede workshop that was happening here
on campus to evaluate the commercial
potential of his clean tech idea the
precede workshop is a team-oriented
hand-picked team that is made up of a
tech transfer officer a licensing
executive a seasoned entrepreneur a
facilitator and coach to walk them
through the 20 questions they need to
ask before investing another 10,000
hours to see if that technology is worth
commercializing and by the way only one
of those questions concerns the
technological aspects of it so it's very
important for that idea to go forward to
really consider you know is anybody
gonna buy the product it doesn't solve
any problems who are the competitors how
are you going to set up your team where
are you gonna get your funding and so on
so as a result of best referrals and
networking at this pre-state workshop
this post I actually assembled a
business team to complement complement
his scientific expertise and together
they applied for and were awarded a New
York State Energy grant to talk to their
first 40 potential customers and get
feedback before they even develop their
prototype to see whether it would be
worthwhile moving forward they decided
yes it was and an equally good outcome
would have been no it isn't and that's
also a success in our eyes and they
actually started the company and they're
calling it eco electro and have since
won an Small Business Innovation
research grant to move forward on this
technology
he's now full-time with the company so
that's his path so key elements of these
stories are always that it includes good
mentoring and your advisor might not be
your only mentor many times faculty are
here because they love academia and
might not have experience in other
fields so we want to connect you with
multiple mentors there's a little S at
the end here in red from the field of
your career aspiration who might meet
with you regularly
encourage you to stay on track and help
you succeed in your career of choice I
should note that we do not assign
mentors that should be a process where
you have a good chemistry with someone
who gives you advice and so we don't
want to interfere with your process so
in the science policy track which is
spearheaded by Chris Shaffer who's the
COPE principle investigator on this best
grant he actually took a sabbatical year
to be a Science and Technology Policy
fellow himself in senator marques office
and came back with the message that
scientists and engineers are by far the
worst storytellers ever and so he
developed a course called the science
policy boot camp from concept to
conclusion which now has had several
it's a team oriented class that has had
several iterations now where there are
tangible projects where teams from
different areas of scientific and
non-scientific disciplines get together
to create an outcome that will address
their passion so for instance there were
a couple of students who thought that it
was really important to teach
algorithmic thinking early on not in the
first coding class that you get as an
undergraduate and so they developed with
a local elementary school principal they
developed a grant got outside funding
and deployed this code for kids program
to 120 second through sixth graders to
improve their algorithmic thinking so
they're making a difference locally on
another group I mentioned the advancing
science and policy graduate student
organization has developed a bring a
politician to work and they've already
had several sessions where they invent
invited if it mayor sponte myrick to
come in they toured a various labs here
he is in a child cognition lab in Maya
cuz a justice all Islam
we're actually a child was teaching him
how to do the experiment so it was a fun
event he toured several other labs
including an imaging lab and so on and
then had a group discussion with grad
students and postdocs who might be
interested in seeing how politicians
actually get their scientific
information to inform their policies we
also had Barbara Lipton come in and she
also did the same kind of thing where
she toured several labs and it's a it's
a great way to hear firsthand how you
can describe your research to someone
who might have last had math in high
school for instance so it's a different
way of thinking about how you describe
your work and these these aspects of
communication will help you if you're
going to teach an undergraduate class or
if you're going to mentor another
postdoc in your lab so in the science
communication area we've had an example
where best trainee was paired with a
science communication professional to
hone her skills in writing a press
release she learned how to conduct
interviews sometimes it's really hard to
get scientists and engineers to talk
cogently about their research in a way
that's going to interest the broader
public so she actually worked on the
structure and mechanics of writing a
piece like that which is very different
from a scientific paper learned about
the editing process as she sent in her
article to the Chronicle and had several
articles published
she helped co-organized with a team of
other people comm saikhan and
communicating science conference which
now is in its third year at Cornell
entirely student-run they learn all
about event planning and rallying the
resources needed and Priscilla tizen
about a grand idea that you might want
to to move your agenda forward and
that's not unlike what faculty do every
day when they have new ideas they want
to implement
so she's actually communicated in a
communication role she's about to start
that role now so lessons learned are
that flexibility and customization is
essential but is very hard to scale so
that's our problem but it's a good
success we think sorry this should be
faculty buy-in faculty buy-in is very
important and we want you to have
conversations with your advisor you
might just have a perception that
they're not receptive to you going into
another career our programming
assessment really helps prune less
successful ideas and we always look at
the evaluations to help inform future
participants and we've stopped doing
things all together when we've had bad
reviews so thanks for filling out any
surveys that you might have been doing
so again we emphasize a primary
objective is to complete your degree we
do meet with faculty as needed to
address questions perceptions and we do
discontinue best privileges if if we
hear that there's been inadequate
academic progress we collaborate very
heavily across units because we're a
very small office and so we have
connections in the Graduate School
Career Services alumni affairs we work
closely with the office of postdoctoral
studies and various student
organizations and professional
organizations on and off campus as I
said we try to identify gaps and and
coordinate to fill those in so best is
not for everyone
and that's fine and we'd like to
concentrate on sharing the positive
messages and not Express a doom and
gloom attitude of how difficult it is to
get one particular career or another
because frankly any career you go into
you have to be passionate and you have
to be willing to work hard so that's
kind of our message we have an advisory
board that's made up exclusively of grad
students and postdocs
and they're really integral in shaping
our program and in event planning and
outreach to other participants across
campus we're at an adaptable program our
vision and components are flexible and
we have some challenges in evaluation
because the NIH is very concerned about
time to degree which might or might not
be the right question to ask because we
think that if you spend two months let's
say in an internship and find out that
maybe you don't need to do it three-year
postdoc you will have saved some time
long term so we'd like to engage in
those conversations whether they're
politically correct right now or not
we're very inclusive and we would like
to imagine persisting outcomes we're in
now our fourth year of a five-year grant
so we have two more years left and at
the end of that we're expected to be
institutionalized so the best of our
best practices we hope will be
incorporated so that's already happening
we have courses that are happening
there's a physics course on science
communication that incorporates
theatrical and Performing Arts aspects
into how you engage your audience in
those first 10 minutes of your talk
we've developed workshops and
certificate programs that are continuing
we involve PhDs in programs that prior
to the best program involvement they
were not eligible for friend says
internships at small life sciences
companies and we hope to be developing a
new paradigm for PhD training whereas
previously it was thought that your
faculty member should mentor you
throughout your PhD which would of
course lead to a postdoc and probably an
academic career unless you've kind of
fell by the wayside somewhere else and
ended up finding your own way in some
other career so instead the consortium
which has published this and the fasiq
journal just a few years ago would like
to think more about your scientific and
research training to incorporate career
and professional development throughout
the time that you're doing your PhD such
that you can decide
whether a postdoc is good for you or not
and to help you be successful in any
career that you decide to pursue so in
fact we have researchers on campus mic
roaches in the dyson school and he
partnered with Henry Sherman to publish
the science paper recently that actually
showed that yes if you're going into an
academic career as a tenure track
professor
you probably will have a postdoc and
you'll need it however if you're going
into an industry career or into an
academic non research position actually
it might be a financial loss to you if
you want to go into that career and so
you should really think about that and
think carefully about the skills you
want to acquire during your postdoc such
that they will get you better prepared
for where you want to end up so what are
the career aspirations of our best
trainees well we compare when you began
your PhD in the light gray here the
majority think they want to become
tenure-track faculty maybe they haven't
even thought about it they just assumed
that was the where they wanted to go
however when we asked them how about now
we find the biggest shift is in other
areas such as consulting
entrepreneurship and communication
careers so we hope to empower you to own
your own career and to be successful
wherever you're going to end up here's
my contact information I want to thank
the principle investigator of the grant
Avery August he's a faculty member in
immunology and infectious disease in the
vet school the co P I is John Parker
he's in virology at the Baker Institute
and of copia I mentioned Chris Shaffer
he's a professor in biomedical
engineering on Suzi var be honest and
please contact me if you'd like to have
more information thank you for your time
I'll entertain questions both from here
and from Geneva there are any
[Applause]
yeah so um there are there is tracking
of Cornell alumni that go on to further
career degrees so we consider that still
in training so if they go to medical
school or law school for instance or
they go on for another master's let's
say in public health after their PhD we
didn't include those statistics in the
outcomes but certainly those we have
examples of those so the question is if
you go on to a non tenure-track position
that are still in academia presumably
like where where are they right right so
they might be an academic research still
or they might be a core facility
director I mean we have PhDs here at
Cornell who run the genomics facilities
imaging facilities and so on so people
without phd's we we have not tracked
them here because our program is
dictated by the NIH to focus on PhD
recipients because many people like me
leave with their masters and they have
fulfilling careers but usually master's
programs or people who exit with their
masters from a ph.d program so that the
master's degree programs usually are
well served in their career objectives
in fact on day one they're told to go to
the career fair for instance so it's a
compressed
his very job oriented those who decide
they started with a ph.d program and
decided to leave with a master's that's
a different situation and I have
counseled some in that category as well
some have gone on to successful industry
positions they realized they didn't need
a PhD for where they wanted to end up
some of them end up coming back for a
PhD after working for a while because
they realize there's a ceiling for
masters students or master's degree
recipients in the field that they want
to go into some have ended up in public
policy and are working on maternal-fetal
nutritional health and and and so on so
but I don't have the statistics here I
could look into those well if you so
that's an individual decision we can't
make a blanket statement it obviously
depends on your field and where you want
to end up but as many people see you
will get paid much more and you you
might just as a question about having a
postdoc is necessary is a PhD necessary
is also a question you should have and
we encourage people to make that thought
before they enroll into the ph.d program
but if you haven't given thought to that
it's an important question and that's
why it's important to talk to people who
are in the field that you want to go
into and that's one thing I did I
counseled the person who was leaving
with their masters she's very happily as
a process engineer at Pfizer right now
and she she chose to leave with her
master's degree but I connected her with
people who either did have their PhD or
did not have their PhD so she could have
a comparison of what the both the salary
level and the advancement levels are for
that degree outcome
teaching either four-year liberal arts
college research focused also on a
community college is there an area for
students that decide they want to go
even though we are in academia it's a
very different thing during the research
versus having a really strong
absolutely so the question is on how
about teaching focused careers either if
you want to go to a community college or
K through 12 environment or at a
four-year liberal arts college so
actually our program doesn't cover
teaching at all because we have an
excellent center for teaching excellence
and we have CU circle which is part of a
like a forty eight institution
consortium that provides information
about teaching and academic careers in
fact I brought their brochures today
because I think it's very important
career outcome to support and so we work
very closely with them they have a great
academic job search series and mentoring
series and how to flip the classroom and
use other teaching techniques
okay so the other question is funding
for best friendships so that's an
ongoing discussion for all our
consortium because there are different
models so for large companies usually
they will pay for the person to do an
internship it's a no brainer however
there are certain international students
due to visa restrictions that can't get
paid in which case that was actually one
of the on campus best friendships that
we arranged so they worked in the
licensing office but actually weren't
paid but they got that experience anyway
so there's almost every possible
combination you can think of to address
how they address the tuition payments
and enrollment situation so it's done on
an individual
and it's really hard to make a blanket
statement about that there have been
departments on campus that created a
course called internships and
experiential opportunities and as long
as it's offered to all students not just
international students it's not seen as
a way to get around federal rules that's
been an option that some universities
have used we'd like to adhere to the
Fair Labor Standards Act which means if
you are adding value
you must get paid and we want to address
the perception that grad students and
postdocs should not shortchange
themselves they shouldn't undersell
themselves they a lot of skills they
probably shouldn't volunteer for an
unpaid internship unless it's really for
their training and the only way they can
get their experience under their belt I
think there are ways of showing the
value that you're going to add to a
company even or even a small institution
now there are nonprofits which have zero
money to be able to pay you in which
case sometimes there are creative ways I
don't want to say to launder money but
to circulate the funds such that we can
reimburse the company let's say for
their training time or for the
consulting that the student does we can
pay for travel and accommodations if
they go to a place so maybe they don't
get paid per se while there but there's
some mitigation that we can make so that
it's more accessible some people have
taken leaves of absence and others just
do it on the side so it's really a
smorgasbord
yeah we're we're not so the question was
about whether the best friendships are
pre-arranged or whether it's up to the
trainee to to find that we have done it
both ways
so sometimes a faculty member has one of
their students who went off and started
a consulting company and they just got
an SBIR grant and they're looking for a
trainee that's how that student got that
policymaking job they sent it to me and
I send it out say hey who's interested
they apply and then they were accepted
for that other times it's the trainee
and you know the best that the best fit
is gonna be one you create yourself
right because I don't know what you want
I don't know your career fields
necessarily and so the most meaningful
interactions will be those that you've
found yourself or created yourself
however to make that easier we do have a
list of all the biopharmaceutical
companies that have formal internship
sites so you can click once and get
right to their internships and jobs page
so we try and save you some time in
doing that so you don't have as big a
search we have a list of all the major
think tanks for instance or we have a
list of all the professional societies
that you know maybe you want to become
more involved in the fight of
pathological Society to arrange student
symposium on career development or
communication or something so we try and
create those links to make it a little
bit easier for you to do your own
homework
if Geneva has any questions like the
thing is I can't hear them so we don't
thank you so much we can all hear you
cool if we wanted to just we best come
up to Geneva to do like presentations or
we have students to participate up here
or
on the other end is their way through
when you bring in speakers that are
presenting down on main campus like are
they in rooms that are compatible with
this system so that we can conference
them in toss up here okay to answer your
first question just invite me and to
answer your second question we would
need a student who's enterprising to set
up that connection and so we we could if
you have the rooms then we could create
that opportunity so let's say if we want
to have a speaker in here we could do
that if somebody's willing to provide
the technology to connect you so yeah we
want to include you so the question as I
understand is on how the word gets
around about the best programs do we
have allies in different units or how
does the word get around so to be honest
when I took this position we had a
cohort model where I said I could handle
about 50 or 60 students and now their
first executive board meeting we changed
our vision and said we need to be open
to everybody so now we have about 350 60
but we touch over 1100 so the bandwidth
is low for doing active marketing but
that's why I have an advisory board so
our advisory board has members from 10
different fields
hopefully the word of mouth gets around
to those fields I also have a listserv
where anybody could join I also often
email the Graduate field assistants and
DG s's for each of the fields our
program started focused in the
biomedical fields how
it's stem wide and so we've done some
outreach to faculty department meetings
which is this kind of setup we've done
road shows to to those existing faculty
meetings and we have a website that we
hope people will go to our target
predominantly has been grad students and
postdocs so we advertising that post
doctoral newsletter in my graduate
school announcements and other things
where I grad students and postdocs hang
out but there's still people who never
hear about it and I think that's a
challenge at Cornell in general about
how to communicate all the fabulous
resources that are at everyone's
disposal so the question is about
institutionalization how the program
will continue beyond the life of our
grants and so I'm working on that end
because I'll also be looking at the next
opportunity
right because that's what I do hundred
percent of my time so we write support
letters for grants where perhaps a
portion of the training would be done
through the best program and then
supported on the ground we have a
proposal into the graduate school who's
working with the provost and chief
financial officer to see what can be
done there but those are ongoing
discussions now other consortium members
have different models for that as well
many of them have like a give button
right on their best site where alumni
can donate to their program or they work
with an industry organization to
hopefully have you know New Jersey bio
Fund internships for graduate students
and postdocs so everybody has it kind of
a different model Wayne State the P I
happens to be the Dean so she just takes
it out of her Dean pocket and gives it
to the best program so you know they're
different models that are that are
working and I think it might be a
combination of all those
and it might be that we concentrate our
efforts and reduce our offerings to the
areas where we're making the most
difference which is why our evaluations
are so important this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu